er liegt hinter dieser tür der derzeit
berühmteste patient der berliner charité
putins erzfeind alexej nawalny nachdem
er gestern kurz nach halb neun war es im
koma liegend mit einem privatjet in
berlin-tegel eingeflogen wurde und dann
mit einem intensiv mobil einem spezial
krankenwagen und auf einer spezialtrage
einem sogenannten isolator in die
charité eingeliefert wurden und jetzt
rätseln wir fragen wir uns und fragt
sich die ganze welt eine medizinische
frage vor allen dingen wie geht sie
natürlich und wie wurde alexej nawalny
vergiftet und wir alle stellen uns eine
politische frage welche rolle spielt
dabei putin
das wollen wir hier diskutieren heute
live bei bild die richtigen fragen und
dazu bei mir zu gast eine kleine aber
tolle runde jaka bizilj ist zu uns
gekommen der gründer von cinema for
peace ein vertrauter von alexei navalny
er hat den rettungsflug aus dem
sibirischen omsk nach berlin organisiert
außerdem der grünen außenexperte jürgen
trittin bei uns herzlich willkommen und
zugeschaltet aus bayern und hier sehen
sie ihn auch manfred weber den chef der
konservativen evp-fraktion im
eu-parlament und csu-vize in allen
herzlich willkommen und die erste frage
jetzt hätte ich bei der vorstellung fast
garri kasparow vergessen den wir schon
aus den usa sehen und gleich mit ihm ein
längeres interview führen können den
früheren schachweltmeister und auch er
gilt als einer der schärfsten gegner
putins mit ihm sprechen wir aus den usa
zugeschaltet gleich erste frage aber
anja k wie sie bei uns im studio wie
gesagt sie ein enger vertrauter von
alexei navalny was können sie jetzt
heute ganz aktuell zu seinem
gesundheitszustand sagen wir haben die
form der charité getroffen dass sobald
wir in berlin angekommen sind natürlich
die charité und die aussage
deutungshoheit hat und diese nun ihre
aussagen die zusammenarbeit mit der
familie der frau machen wird die wären
aber einiges mit ihrem mann gestern
gelandet
wir haben natürlich auch mit dem
medizinischen fragen zu tun gehabt
diesen zwei tagen wo diesen transport
organisiert haben wo es hin und her ging
ist ja wie wir alle wissen wurde er
mehrmals behauptet er wer nicht
transportfähig und daraufhin mussten wir
dann damit sich im bericht erstellen
lassen
also fakt ist dass ihnen dieser flug
nicht geschwächt hat ihn gut überstanden
was aber nichts an der
besorgniserregenden gesamtsituation
ändert
sie haben gerade seine ehefrau
angesprochen julia navalny was können
sie über sie sagen wie geht sie mit
diesem gewaltigen druck beispielsweise
um sie machte auf mich einen gefassten
eindruck
man konnte die erleichterung anmerkte
dass regieren endlich raus ging dass sie
angekommen ist in einem
hochqualifizierten modernen krankenhaus
ich bin mir sicher dass in russland auch
sehr gute ärzte gibt aber man konnte er
den fotos sehen aus den von den
gegebenheiten dort das einfach dort
nicht dieser standard herrscht die man
hier bei der charity haben kann aber für
die krankenhäuser der welt liegt derweil
weiter im koma wissen sie dass mein
letzter stand der dinge war von gestern
dass das der fall war
was die heutigen ereignisse angeht die
auch mit der familie besprochen worden
sind ich würde mal vermuten dass die
charité sich nächsten ein zwei tagen
dazu äußern wird aber ich nehme ganz
bewusst da nicht weit weiter teile an
diesen gesprächen ich war schon bereits
überfordert als wir an dem kritischen
tag an dem freitag ist entscheidungen zu
treffen hatten diese beurteilung
vorzunehmen ob das deutsch deutsche
ärzte team nun am das overrule kann was
die russischen ärzte dort von sich
gegeben aber was zum teil relativ
unsinnige war zum teil aber auch eine
berechtigung hatte und wie dann auf
einmal der lage waren medizinische
sachverhalte beurteilen zu müssen von
denen wir nichts verstehen
hier ist es ganz kleine medizinische und
keine politische diagnose die gestellt
werden wird und gestellt werden soll
warum eigentlich deutschland gab es
andere optionen noch für dabei nie
er hatte hatte etliche einladungen zu
verschiedenen orten kliniken sowohl in
deutschland wie auch in frankreich und
marco und merkel haben das auch
öffentlich im fernsehen auch angeboten
ich glaube die haben sich dafür
entschieden und habe ich das einfach
angerufen weil peter wersedorf eine sehr
gute erfahrungen der charité vor zwei
jahren gemacht hatte und peter version
of und natur ikone weit ist man noch die
beiden dem ich am donnerstag vormittag
angerufen
zu haben und gebeten haben ob ich ihren
freunden aber helfen könnte wir haben
oft in der vergangenheit jürgen trittin
darüber diskutiert ob wir wirklich hart
genug gegenüber putin gegenüber russland
sind oder waren hatte es in dem fall
geholfen möglicherweise nav allen hier
raus zu bekommen dass man bei der eine
oder andere politische frage in der
vergangenheit nicht ganz so hart klar
klare oder harte kante gegenüber putin
gezeigt hat ich glaube dass die großen
koalition seit 2005 ein lernprozess
durchgemacht haben anfang hat man ja
noch davon gesprochen dass russland
unter putin ein strategischer partner
deutschlands wir haben das immer
kritisiert weil wir gesagt haben
strategischer partner geht nicht mit
einer autokratie gleichzeitig hat die
deutsche bundesregierung aber die
gesprächsmöglichkeiten nachdem sie ihre
positionen verändert hat dennoch ein
stück weit erhalten und möglicherweise
ist dies der grund warum die russische
führung gemeint hat man ihn nach
deutschland gehen lassen zu können ohne
dass dazu einem gesichtsverlust führt
also eher weber das navalny nach
deutschland ausgeflogen wurde ist ein
zeichen dafür dass das verhältnis
zwischen merkel und putin ein ganz gutes
ist ist das so dass eine bessere
perspektive wir alex eine rolle gibt das
ist das wichtigste ist zunächst mal die
jetzige situation politisch betrachtet
müssen wir jetzt einfach auf die
expertise von den ärzten in der charité
warten das ist ja der große vorteil den
wir jetzt haben die genossen in großen
band in die entwicklung politisch bringt
nämlich dass wir jetzt realität auswärts
ein ordentliches assessment bekommen und
danach beurteilen können wie die
hintergründe ausschauen aber es liegt
natürlich auf der hand wir haben ja
nicht nur alexej nawalny wir haben ja
auch boris nemzow wie man aus den
vergangenen jahren zu nennen wären
hunderte vielleicht tausende von
namenlosen in russland die für freiheit
der demokratie für rechtsstaatlichkeit
eintreten und gegen dieses autokratische
system abonnieren und und das dass das
system putin gegenschläge ausführt liegt
auch daran dass
brauchen wir als europäer nicht mehr ist
und dabei die konkrete sorge die ja auch
zurzeit wenn wir jetzt die bilder
belarus sie die konkrete sorge die
glaube ich die putin am meisten umtreibt
ist dass diese idee von freiheit dass
sich die richtung osten vor kämpft
richtung russland auch vor künftig haben
sie ja weber denn den verdacht dass in
dieser frage bei dieser offensichtlichen
vergiftung navalny ist der staat
dahinter steht
wir alle können nur spekulieren aber die
zusammenhänge denke ich sind sind neu
wir haben in wenigen wochen in russland
regionalbahn 13 neue regionen bällen
auch der neue regionen wählen dann ein
gouverneur wie die wahlen ausgehen sind
für putins system wichtig die
zustimmungsraten zu ihm als präsident
aber auch zu seiner partei bei den
massiven den keller
wir haben seit 2014 wirtschaftliche
stagnation in russland also das ist
alles etwas was das system putin massiv
unter druck setzt und in dem rahmen der
situation glaube ich ist putin auch zu
vielem fähig und dazu gehört auch das
töten von menschen
er tritt ihn gehen auch sie davon aus
haben sie diesen verdacht dass das eine
vergiftung durch bzw im auftrag putins
sein könnte ich würde erstmal den befund
der charité abwarten was wir wissen ist
in das ist auf anna politkowskaja auf
verschiedene andere oppositionelle
giftanschläge gegeben hat wir wissen
dass bekannte oppositionelle boris
nemzow office genannt worden direkt vor
der haustür von putin erschossen worden
sind es ist im prinzip egal oder ich
weiß nicht was schlimmer ist ob es eine
anweisung gab der zentrale solche
oppositionelle zu liquidieren
oder ob unterhalb dieser zentrale die
machtkämpfe der verschiedenen
machtgruppen innerhalb dieser autokratie
nicht mehr zu kontrollieren sind und
dies zu diesen aktionen führt schauen
sie ich bin mir nicht sicher ob zum
beispiel alle in russischen machtapparat
froh darüber sind dass der
generalbundesanwalt festgestellt hat
dass hier im tiergarten ein auftragsmord
an hat gefunden dazu kommen wir einen
tag später noch heute aber wenn sie
zusammen
das problem ist wenn putin das nicht
mehr unter kontrolle hat
dann ist damit das wesen die wesentliche
erzählung das wesentliche narrativen
seiner herrschaft und frage gestellt
nämlich dass er für stabilität und
sicherheit für russland sagt das ist ja
hochspannend die frage heute haben wir
gehört meldungen die aus dem russischen
geheimdienst kommen da hat man offen
gelegt wie man alexej nawalny in den
stunden bevor er dann in den
krankenwagen musste und ins krankenhaus
nach oben es musste beschattet hat ihn
auf schritt und tritt verfolgt hat dh da
wurde genauer offengelegt wie dicht der
geheimdienst dann dran war aber
komischerweise im entscheidenden moment
darüber gibt es dann keine informationen
halten sie das für glaubwürdig diese
informationen wie erklären sie sich auch
dass diese informationen habe sie
überhaupt rauskommen aus dem osten sieht
wo es so aus dass man sich damit eben
auch ein bisschen frei stellen wollte
nach dem motto wir haben ja gut betreut
und werden ja mitbekommen wenn was
passiert wäre also ist auffällig dass
für diese anschläge die wir aus der
vergangenheit kennt tatsächlich über
über heißen tee erfolgt sünden
litvinenko wurde wurde quasi aber
komischerweise gibt es ja genau über
diesen moment eben da war dann offenbar
laut dieses berichtes zumindest kein
geheimdienst mitarbeiter in der nähe als
dieses foto entstand dann der auf dem
eben
derweil nie diesen welcher thema
interessant an der politik sculley
später erschossen wurde ist auch schon
fast vorher gestorben 22 jahre vorher
auch mit einem t auch bei peter wf ging
es ging man davon aus dass es über eine
flüssigkeit passiert ist scheint wurde
eine gängige methode zu sein
inwiefern da der staat involviert ist
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass herr
putin recht war es zum beispiel anna
politkowskaja und am geburtstag ermordet
wurde als ich weiß nichts schöneres
geburtstagsgeschenk dass ihm das recht
war oder das wie sie schon oder winter
boris nemzow vor seiner haustür getötet
wurde
ich glaube es geht vor allem darum eben
in ein land im griff zu behalten dass
solche dinge nicht passieren dass
journalisten oder eben auch
oppositionspolitiker nicht ermordet
werden und ich glaube dass die große
herausforderung wenn man mit russland
als strategischen partner als
ernsthaften partner am haben recht
halten sie das herr weber für möglich
dass navalny zb dort am flughafen oder
später im flugzeug vergiftet wurde und
putin weiß nichts davon
das ist ja sehr spekulative frage wie
wir wissen es wir wissen es nicht aber
die die hintergründe dramen das system
die sich damit verbindet das ist für
jedermann offensichtlich und deswegen
geht es für uns europäer eigentlich
darum zunächst hilfe zu leisten
an der seite von ihnen zustehen die für
freiheit demokratie rechtsstaat
eintreten und zum zweiten geht es darum
richtigen weg zu finden mit russland
umzugehen so dass keine weitere
eskalation im inneren ein dritter
trittin hat ja auch die brüche im
inneren des systems hingewiesen und es
gibt natürlich schon eine große angst
eine große sorge
all diese systeme sowie lukaschenko
boulahrouz sowie putin in moskau erleben
oder würden ja nicht einen normalen
regierungswechsel erleben wenn es zum
sturz käme
bei denen in diesem system jedes jahr um
alles so macht und geld vielleicht
kommst persönliche liegen und in so
einer situation ist natürlich
er ist eine große gefahr dass wenn das
system sich die stabilisiert
radikalisierte sich dann und das will
niemand das will auch in europa niemand
wir wollen den dialog wir wollen
miteinander reden wir wollen ins
gespräch kommen
wir wollen das gespräch suchen aber
immer auf basis unserer reagiert eben
nicht verhandelt aus dem europa klar
machen muss dass wir noch nicht trocken
und wenn es sein muss auch zu
weitergehenden schritten in der lage
sind und das sind eben dann auch
sanktionen
also das heißt wenn sie hier ich habe es
verstanden dass sie alle
verständlicherweise nicht spekulieren
wollen aber wenn sich der verdacht den
sie auch geäußert haben er weber
bestätigen sollte dann sind weitere
schritte notwendig seitens der eu
seitens der bundesregierung und sie
nennen sanktionen das ist geradezu
belagert seinen eu gibt für gab wenige
tage danach den defekten wahlen dieser
starkes zeichen dass europa in der
ostpolitik richtung belassen russland
sensibel ist und dass wir auch
vergleichsweise klein sind das ist ein
positives signal und ich für die
europäische volkspartei wie die größte
partei im europäischen parlament sage
klar dass weitergehen die sanktionen
gegenüber russland auf dem tisch liegen
wir müssen handlungsfähig sein wir
müssen die stärkste stärkste tool das
wir haben nämlich unsere
wirtschaftsmacht dass europäer in der
hand halten um steht bald auch den
dialog und das miteinander wird dann
auch zuletzt wegen der sanktionen liegen
am tisch und das dann auch einsetzen
nämlich ein herr weber absolut wir waren
schon dazu in der lage und eine weitere
weitere verschärfung muss muss denkbar
sein ist eine option für die europäische
union sollten wir weitere eskalationen
den beiden fällen erleben sowohl in der
inneren opposition in russland als auch
in der frage was sie hat retina ich
davon aus dass einer weile jetzt dort im
koma liegend in der berliner charité
sicher ist wir haben gesehen wie streng
bewacht wird oder muss man dort weitere
sorge haben mein eindruck war von der
begleitung des intensiven krankenwagens
dass dort relativ polen viel polizei
unterwegs war und ich kann mir schon gut
vorstellen dass die berliner und die
bundespolizei in der lage sind in
umfassend zu schützen da habe ich
vertrauen
banken alle mit alexei navalny sie ganz
besonders weil sie einen persönlichen
bezug zu ihm haben gehen sie im moment
nach diesen bildern wir haben es gesehen
ein intensiv mobil in diesem isolator es
er transportiert worden davon aus dass
er irgendwann wieder der alte sein kann
oder muss man doch davon ausgehen ich
sage das jetzt ein bisschen flapsig dass
er im grunde als politiker aus dem weg
geräumt ist ich glaube ich vermute mal
dass der status der ist dass er das
überleben wird das ist so meine
interpretation der letzten zwei drei
tage weil sich als nicht mediziner
wahrgenommen habe ja und wird jetzt auch
nicht vorgreifen was die charité nun zu
vermelden haben wird aber aus meiner
sicht entscheidende frage ist genau das
was sie gerade artikulieren
ob er das unbeschadet übersteht und eben
seine rolle bald einnehmen kann und ich
glaube dass das auch wahrscheinlich
nicht nächsten zwei drei tagen
feststehen wird sondern dass das
womöglich ein längerer weg sein wird
das heißt er wird vermutlich davon ist
moment auszugehen nicht diese aktive
rolle als politiker spielen können das
ist ja das entscheidende gewesen seine
bedeutende rolle für die opposition in
russland das heißt sollte es sein ziel
der regierung in russland gewesen sein
neben politisch zu schaden offenbar ist
das gelungen also war peter werder so
dass sich haiti nach einigen teilen der
34 45 tagen schon feststellen konnte
dass er das höchstwahrscheinlich alles
unbeschadet überstehen wird und
halluzinogene drei vier wochen immer
noch also seiner drei wochen auch so
eine hauskatze und uns sah also den
vorsitzende charité professor innerhalb
als gefängniswärter schickte mir
nachrichten habe ich endlich aus dem
gefängnis raus holen könnte also der war
einfach einen monat geistig komplett out
of order und hat er noch danach noch ein
monat bei uns in berlin gewohnt also
jetzt sehe ich das war eine sache von
zwei drei monate ich glaube drei monate
und ich vermute mal dass das in diese
richtung hier auch gehen wird so wenn er
das unbeschadet übersteht was wir alle
hoffen dass er sicherlich trotzdem
mindestens 12 monate sind politischen
gefecht weg wir wollen einmal die runde
erweitern sie haben gerade schon sein
gesicht gesehen und wir wollen mit garri
kasparow sprechender uns zugeschaltet
ist aus den usa der frühere
schachweltmeister wir kennen ihn alle
und eben auch russische oppositionelle
putin gegner
ihnen herzliche grüße nach amerika und
schön dass wir mit ihnen sprechen können
immer wieder fiel in dieser runde das
wort und gleich hören wir sie
hoffentlich auch hier immer wieder viele
in dieser runde gerade das wort
spekulation wir wollen nicht weiter
spekulieren ist es wilde spekulationen
wenn wir im moment sagen navalny ist
offenbar vergiftet worden und dahinter
könnte putin stecken oder ist das ein
ganz offensichtlicher und naheliegend
dass schluss nach den informationen der
letzten tage
[Musik]
sie haben natürlich bereits erwähnt dass
auch die selben symptome hatte der war
ja auch an der charité
es gab fälle das sind das menschen sogar
mehrfach vergiftet wurden sie haben ja
alle anna politkowskaja bereits erwähnte
ja auch einmal vergiftet worden war
mit einem tee und dann war das nicht
erfolgreich und später wurde sie an
putins geburtstag 2006 erschossen
es gibt eine ganz ganz lange liste von
putins gegner die starben plötzliche
herz und fragte vergiftungen erschossen
stellen sie sich mal vor dass dieser
versuch dass das ohne die führung hätte
passieren können er ist natürlich ein
fake präsident dieser putin als ein
diktator
also sprechen sie doch einfach nicht
über wahlen das ist total unter
kontrolle von putins partei
navalny hat die natürlich eine bande von
dieben und gangstern genannte und hat
völlig recht damit und natürlich gut ins
fahrende hassen allem aber nicht weil
sie korruption anprangert man sich
überhaupt vorstellen dass jemand der
ballen die angreifer ohne dass putin
davon wusste dass er das abgesegnet hat
putin schaut jetzt natürlich noch viel
ruß und der hat
dass die das russische volk aufsteht so
wie es im augenblick in belarus zu sehen
ist
und jetzt ist natürlich der wahl nicht
aus dem spiel und das waren natürlich
einen ganz naheliegende schluss aus dem
spiel sagen sie die frage haben wir hier
gerade schon diskutiert gehen sie damit
davon aus herr kasparow das navalny auf
lange sicht als politischer gegner
wirklich abgeräumt ist aus putins ich
freue mich natürlich zunächst erklärt
dass er in sicherheit in berlin ist und
ich bete dafür dass er sich völlig
erholen wird wir haben ja natürlich noch
keine gesicherten informationen von der
charité aber ich habe großes vertrauen
zu den deutschen ärzten und ich hoffe
seinen körper übersteht das unbeschadet
ich weiß nicht was passieren wird wann
oder ob er sich völlig erholen wird und
weiß nicht aber das risiko noch mal ein
irgendwie wieder zurück nach russland zu
gehen oder sein kampf außerhalb
russlands fortsetzen wird
es gibt dafür viele einfach nur die wahl
russland zu verlassen oder weiter in
gefahr zu bleiben was er unternommen hat
darf überhaupt nicht unterschätzt wird
er hat so viel gegen die korruption und
putin system gekämpft das ist eine große
leistung
während wir sprechen
putin weiter die deutschen
handelsbeziehungen schauen natürlich mit
dem russischen gas viele sehr gute
geschäfte mit russland machen und wenn
sie wenn ich weiter diese russischen
rohstoffe kaufen dann stärkt es
natürlich das boot in system
spätestens jetzt sagen sie und sie
äussern ja mehr als ein verdacht im fall
wally navalny ist für sie der zeitpunkt
gekommen für sie vermutlich schon vorher
aber dass sie sagen spätestens jetzt
muss das gasgeschäft mit russland aus
deutscher sicht aufhören stopp von
jining
so lange das so weiter geht und so lange
sie weiter diese nord stream reißen und
ähnliche handelsabkommen dann ist wie
putin diese sanktion egal bleibt einem
nur die möglichkeit dann irgendwann das
land zu verlassen wenn man als
oppositioneller als putin gegner
weiterleben möchte sie haben das für
sich entschieden sie sind sozusagen ins
exil gegangen leben in amerika glauben
sie dass sie irgendwann in ihrem leben
zurückkehren werden und was vermissen
sie im moment am meisten an ihrem land
an russland und verwandte und ich habe
kein zweifel daran dass russlands
zurückfahren
ein durchstart haus und was in belarus
passiert das war auch in russland
passieren und das ist ja ganz egal was
die diktaturen sagen und überall diese
diese wahlen sind egal sondern das volk
wird auf stehen ich bin ganz ganz
positiv dass ich meinem land helfen kann
wieder in die familie der zivilisation
der zivilisierten staaten zurückzukehren
gerade weißrussland schon angesprochene
kasparow dass die letzte frage
dort haben wir heute wahrscheinlich mehr
als hunderttausend menschen auf der
straße gesehen die mutig sind was sagen
sie den menschen in minsk ii diesen mut
haben und obwohl lukas schenkel sagt
geht nicht auf die straße die dann
trotzdem an diesem sonntag raus gehen
und zu solchen massen friedlich
demonstrieren wie können sie sie weiter
ermutigen dranzubleiben
ich glaube diese mutigen menschen
brauchen keinen weiteren zuspruch von
mir
es könnten sogar heute 250.000 menschen
gewesen sein
solange lukaschenka allerdings glaubt
dass putin hinter ihm steht und ihm
militärisch und natürlich auch mit
geheimdiensten und allem hilft
80 prozent der spieler russischen volkes
war gegen den ausgang dieser wahl ist
gegen den diktator und nur weil
lukaschenko die unterstützung putins hat
kann er so tun als ob ihm das nichts
ausmacht dass diese massen auf der
straße sind die schreien weg mit ihm
danken herzlich für dieses gespräch
garri kasparow toll dass sie unser gast
waren hier live bei bild der frühere
schachweltmeister und erklärter putin
gegner danke und ganz herzliche grüße
nach amerika und wir diskutieren weiter
in der runde vertiefen nachher auch noch
mal weißrussland aber ich würde den
moment noch bei ein paar gedanken auch
von herrn kasper bleiben der ja sehr
sehr hart gegenüber putin formuliert
jemand wir haben gerade über nord stream
gesprochen herr trittin jemand der und
es gibt in den fall des tiergarten
mordes eben in dem die gerne
generalbundesanwalt ja
bundesanwaltschaft ja von staatlichem
tötungsauftrag spricht das heißt jemand
der leute aus dem weg räumen lässt töten
lässt würden sie mit einem solchen
privatgeschäfte machen warum sollte ich
ist das politisch anders macht man mit
einem vielleicht privat keine geschäfte
aber politisch ist das dann möglich wenn
ich wie meine ganz andere region der
welt schweifen wir sprechen gerade über
den schrecklichen explosionen im libanon
da treffen wir auf einen
staatspräsidenten herrn der war der chef
der christlichen milizen im bürgerkrieg
das ist ein massenmörder und wenn sie
andere wie magnetische politiker nehmen
die sie brauchen um das ganze zu regeln
sie treffen immer aber was wollen sie
damit sagen sie können das halbjahr
hinein sind unternehmen der welt sagen
gerade die serie unterscheiden müssen
und dem was die notwendigkeiten sind die
sich aus aussenpolitischen erwägungen
ergeben
das nennt man realpolitik realpolitik
darf nicht die eigenen werte mit füßen
treten sie darf auch nicht die augen zu
machen das ist das was wir an der alten
russland politik die bis ich würde mal
sagen 2010 in deutschland gemacht worden
ist wo man die autokratie
strategischen partner verklärt hat das
heißt aber nicht dass man nicht an
bestimmten stellen mit russland reden
muss wir werden libyen nicht regeln
können nun ohne orale wahl geschäfte
machen reden reden ja geschäfte machen
war die frage sie haben eine situation
dass überall
wir machen geschäfte mit saudi arabien
die hatten jeden freitag menschen den
kopf ab und jetzt konkretere das ist die
bittere not ja sehen sie sich das sind
nicht ganz lustig nord stream
ich habe mal für meine fraktion
gutachten auf den weg gemacht wie wir
mit einer ambitionierten klimaschutz
politik innerhalb eines 10 jahres
zeitraums bis 2030 die menge an erdgas
einsparen können die wir heute aus
russland importieren das ist der
richtige weg dieses zu tun
da sind wir viel für beschimpft und
belacht worten aber ich halte nord
stream nicht für eine bereicherung der
deutschen energie sicherheit sondern für
eine wette gegen die klimaschutzziele
das sei ein anderer ein anderer
gedankengang an dieser stelle nur dieses
realität und die wir heute haben ist
dass die europäische union und sämtliche
mitgliedstaaten der europäischen union
die etwas damit zu tun hatten gegen
unsere frauen zur heilung legen energie
versorgung so begründen die liga sehr
gut anstehen zwar eigentlich der
richtige regel sind das aber sie werden
sagen aus auch das problem was wir heute
haben ist dass die betreiber von nord
stream nach europäischen recht dass eine
lizenz haben dies zu tun das ist
genehmigt und das können sie in einem
rechtsstaat schlecht zurücknehmen also
wenn im fall navalny nachgewiesen wird
dass es auch in diesem fall eine einen
staatlichen tötungsauftrag gegeben haben
wie soll ich dann können sie auch die
mini raten nicht aussteigen das wäre
sein vertrag zwischen die zwischen
deutschland
es gibt eine genehmigung an die firma
das ist das problem und dass auch das
problem dass wir das würde dann mit dem
tor haben das würde dann seriös die usa
die ja selber ungefähr in der gleichen
beträgen öl aus russland beziehen wie
wir gast bezogen haben die usa die die
ersten flüssiggas
transporte die von jamal in sibirien ab
ging in boston an einfließen
das heißt hier gibt es offensichtlich
ein stück doppelmoral und ich sage das
einzige was gegen dinge helft wie nord
stream ist in der tat komplett die
fossile energie 92 weise eine aber sie
sagen auch gleichermaßen jetzt jetzt
gibt's halt diese abmachungen der 700
ich bin skeptisch würden
ich bin halt skeptisch weil ich gelernt
habe dass wenn man einem unternehmen
eine erlaubnis gibt man nicht ohne
schadenersatz da raus kommt von selbst
schadenersatz an russland zahlen ich
nicht wollen sie mit einem
möglicherweise mörder sagt unter anderem
kasparow dieses geschäft machen
ich möchte das nicht sagt das ist die
realität genau so wie es die realität
ist dass wir jeden tag aus saudi arabien
und übrigens auch aus russland nicht nur
gas auf öl beziehen
das ist die die situation und der wir
leben und wenn wir uns davon
verabschieden wollen und werden wir das
nicht mit hilflosen symbolischen
aktionen machen können sondern wir
können das nur indem wir komplett
umsteuern und unsere energieversorgung
komplett klimaneutral machen dann sind
wir nicht mehr auf importe angewiesen
und dann muss ich doch nicht mehr
geschäfte mit verbrechern ihren punkt
verstanden geschäfte mit verbrechern
herr weber sagen sie da kommt man halt
jetzt schwer raus aus der nummer ich
verkürzt das jetzt ein bisschen herr
trittin das ist halt jetzt eine
abmachung an die müssen wir uns halten
egal wie dieser fall navalny steht egal
wie das aufgeklärt wird egal ob
rauskommt dass das möglicherweise ein
staatlicher tötungsauftrag gewesen ist
ich bin nur eine seite von herrn kasper
ich glaube dass nord stream 2 die
entscheidung dass die erlaubnis zu
erteilen und das projekt durchzuführen
ein fehler es wurde ja durchgeführt in
einer zeit wo europa gleichzeitig
wirtschaftliche sanktionen geschlossen
hat ich sage das als europapolitiker der
in eben die größte fraktion im
europäischen parlament wird dann sagen
viele nachbarn in europa nicht
verstanden warum wir durch einerseits
sanktionen gegenüber putin aktivieren
wollen und andererseits bei dass unsere
geschäfte weiter machen
ich glaube übrigens dezidierte sehe eine
andere debatte herr trittin dass wir
ohne gas den umstieg in der
energiepolitik nicht schaffen werden
also wir brauchen gas aber wir sollten
das gas als europäer zu künftig viel
mehr aus anderen weltregionen
importieren dafür gibt's flüssiggas
möglichkeiten wir könnten die
abhängigkeit von russland reduzieren das
wäre der richtige weg gewesen insofern
bin ich da an der seite von kasparov
dass das nicht glaubt wir die geräte für
uns europäer diese gasleitungen zu bauen
und wir haben ja andere projekte auch
noch in der schublade
über die süd über die süd verbindungen
in all diesen bereichen sollten wir
uneinigkeit europa in den mittelpunkt
der gasversorgung stellen das richtig
entschieden
ich bin ja bin ja bei ihnen was was die
ablehnung und wird die überflüssigkeit
von nord stream ein geht aber macht es
dann wirklich sinn mit übrigens
steuergeldern aus europa aus
aserbaidschan von dem autokraten
ensembles aliev über die türkei
das heißt mit dem autokraten erdogan gas
zu beziehen stehen wir da nicht leute
plötzlich an an dieser stelle oder das
heißt wir treiben doch den teufel mit
dem beelzebub aus anstatt zu sagen wir
reduzieren unseren gast verbrauch
insgesamt und zwar radikal verstehe
nicht so argumentieren hier steht
natürlich für die sollten besser in
einem auto bis zur nächsten auf den
zweig einer energiepolitischen debatte
und trotzdem verstehen natürlich wie sie
argumentieren herr weber nur so können
wir hier nicht festhalten das ist der
punkt der putin der den putin verstehen
würde dass es eine sanktion die putin
verstehen würde und den interessiert am
ende nicht ob man wie in weißrussland
irgendwelche wahlergebnisse mal
kurzfristig eher aus brüssel nicht
anerkennt sondern diese sprache das wäre
eine sanktion ihn treffen würde
natürlich versteht er diese sprache
natürlich sagt er dass zum einen steht
dass die größte macht die wir europäer
haben unsere wirtschaftliche macht ist
und ich bin auch der meinung dass die
sanktionen sei 2014 auch wirken wir
haben wie gesagt wirtschaftliche
stagnation in russland die menschen
sehen immer weniger die perspektive
voranzugehen
also ich bin doch sehr dafür dass wir
die option von wirtschaftlichen
sanktionen und von von klarheit in
diesen fragen aufrechterhalten
jetzt wird ihnen ausdrücklich normal ich
glaube man sollte nicht die autokraten
gegeneinander ausspielen wir haben thema
jetzt habt ihr schon deswegen sollten
wir in der arie klare antworten geben
wie wir das europäischer zu stellen ganz
aber ich einen ganz verstanden habe
weber steht jetzt nord stream zwei aus
ihrer 16 disposition oder nicht ich bin
europapolitiker deutsche entscheidung
deswegen muss die bundesregierung müsste
die bundesregierung da noch mal
vorangehen
ich würde sagen dass dies eines der
projekte ist es mit zu den
wirtschaftlichen tragen gehören wenn wir
über optionen reden die am tisch liegen
dann förderindustrie 2002 steht quasi
zur disposition
der ton war gerade weg empfiehlt sich
nicht quälen aber das habe ich noch
nicht verstanden nord sind zwei gehörte
steht für sie zur disposition
nostalgie zwei historische entscheidung
die richtig beschrieben worden ist und
deswegen müssten auch deutsche stellen
über entscheidet auch mal so greg damit
in die wirtschaftlichen überlegungen mit
einzieht
ich sage klar wirtschaftliche
weitergehende wirtschaftliche sanktionen
müssen auf den tisch liegen
europa muss in der entscheidenden phase
in der wir jetzt in den beziehungen zu
unseren östlichen nachbarn sind erklärt
klar sein und da waren wir
beispielsweise in der ukraine dazu
gehört ja klar
und das war auch gut ihn durchaus
überrascht er verstehe sr weber trotzdem
mit der bitte um eine klare antwort ich
frage sie jetzt einfach mal nicht als eu
politiker sondern als csu-vize 19 2
steht so dass positionen oder nicht die
frage die frage das nord stream 2 eines
der projekte ist die wirtschaftliche
bedeutung hat liegt auf der hand
deswegen ist es eines der beispiele wie
putin gegenüber unsere entschiedenheit
deutlich machen können also da gibt es
nichts dazu zu sagen das glaube ich ist
wahr
gemacht das halten wir fest und nehmen
es mit in die nächsten runden ich will
einmal eine brücke schlagen zu dem was
im moment in minsk passiert in
weißrussland herbie ziel ist es totaler
zufall dass wir auf der einen seite
gerade aktuell so schwer über diesen
fall navalny diskutieren müssen dass
dieser mann offenbar vergiftet wurde
während gleichzeitig in minsk
möglicherweise der letzte große diktator
europas fällt es fällt ihm schwer an
zufälle zu glauben natürlich spekulation
aber ist natürlich auffällig absolut und
ich glaube aber insgesamt ich finde die
diskussion natürlich hier sehr wichtig
aber ich denke wir sollten vielleicht
noch größere rahmen denken wir haben vor
vielen jahren dem bruder unterstützt mit
unserer menschenrechts filme und
regisseure von cinema for peace als es
darum ging dass die sanktions gesetz
einzuführen die sekte magnitski gesetze
und der anhaltspunkt war auch die
ermordung seines seines anwaltes im
gefängnis in moskau
und ich habe damals nur die auffassung
vertreten dass sollte nicht gegen
russland gehen sondern sollte eingesetzt
sein das in aller welt herrscht das
heißt was sie angesprochen haben macht
man geschäfte mit
menschenrechtsverbrechen sollte
eigentlich im gesetz auch in deutschland
gefasst werden die die ganze welt
umfassen sie haben von saudi arabien
erwähnt es gibt eine ganze latte von
solchen um solchen fällen und ich denke
dass es da eben auch in verschiedene
schutzmechanismen und menschenrechts
menschenrechts stolz sehr interessant
dann kamen sie mit dem libanon argument
nicht mehr durch ich sage ihnen ich
werde man konsequent wenn ich die
realität beschreiben finde ich sie nicht
gut ich will da nicht missverstanden
werden
die situation die wir noch haben ist wir
werden wir sind konfrontiert in russland
mit einer entwicklung die viele von uns
ja auch überrascht es galt bis dahin so
das bild ja in leningrad dann gibt es
eine lebendige kulturszene
da wird protestiert und wenn es faire
wahlen bei der letzten kommunalwahl
moskau gegeben er hätte die partei
einiges russland keine mehrheit bekommen
aber putin wird getragen von der weite
des landes den ländlichen raum was
passiert in shah barros wählen die ein
gouverneur der ihm nicht passt zwei
jahre später hat weit weg von moskau
äußeres lassen und daraufhin stehen die
menschen dort auf genauso wie in
weißrussland
solidarisieren sich mit weißrussland an
dieser stelle und es zeigt dass diese
herrschaft und unser bild was auch an
kräften in der russischen gesellschaft
ist offensichtlich selbst bei denen die
jedes mal wenn sie in russland sind mit
solchen vertreterinnen und vertretern
sprechen noch verkürzt ist es gibt eine
große unzufriedenheit in russland und
ich glaube die diskussion die wir hier
führen ist eine die sie auch darauf
konzentrieren muss diese kräfte der
zivilgesellschaft zu stärken
ich finde es nach wie vor absurd dass
zum beispiel menschen mit einem
dienstausweis aus boston visafrei
einreisen dürfen aber wir bei
studierenden jungen menschen riesige
probleme machen anstatt zu sagen leute
kommt her
guckt euch an wie es ist in einem land
wo opposition im zweifel auch von der
polizei geschützt und nicht bedroht wir
schauen ja schnell auf die
zivilgesellschaft in weißrussland
nämlich das sind wirklich sie werden die
bilder gesehen haben ganz ganz
beeindruckende szenen die sich da heute
in minsk auf der straße abgespielt haben
das sind mehr als 100000 menschen
gewesen
garri kasparow glaube ich oder jürgen
trittin sagte gerade schon das könnte
eine viertel millionen gewesen sein die
da auf der straße waren das sind
aufnahmen von paul ronzheimer unserem
bild reporter der seit tagen dort
verharrt in minsk und der wahrscheinlich
auch tief beeindruckt ist heute von dem
was da auf den straßen los war
denn paul und gleich sehen wir dich auch
im bild aus - der diktator hat ja dazu
aufgerufen eben nicht rauszugehen nicht
zu demonstrieren und trotzdem haben sich
ganz ganz ganz ganz viele weißrussen
genau daran nicht gehalten haben das
gegenteil gemacht und waren der heute
auf der straße also was bedeutet das für
lukaschenko was sagt das über seine
macht noch im eigenen land aus
du hast es angesprochen wir waren heute
dort auf diesen straßen unterwegs wir
haben von oben drauf schauen können auch
diese massen und wenn man diese menschen
demonstrieren sie wenn man hört wie sie
für ihre freiheit kämpfen dann kann man
gar nicht anders dann bekommt man da
gänsehaut das geht dann so wahnsinnig
wahrscheinlich auch bald ist eben anders
ist als bei anderen protesten die ich
auch erlebt hat überall auf der welt wo
es irgendwann dann gewalttätig wurde
oder zumindest steine geschmissen wurden
oder was auch immer das passiert hier
alles überhaupt nicht auch heute wieder
friedlich völlig friedliche proteste
hunderttausende die da marschiert sind
die dann gesagt haben der lukaschenko
gehört und einen gefangenen transporter
man hat hier gehandelt hat potter ein
bisschen entfernt davon gesehen aber die
waren natürlich nicht für lukaschenko
dort sondern für die demonstranten und
sie hatten natürlich muss sie angst
haben dass sie wieder behaftet würden
dann am ende haben sie den platz
verlassen und lukaschenko hat sich
martialisch gezeigt ist mit dem
hubschrauber eingetroffen bei seiner
residenz wird ein sturmgewehr also bis
sind ganz ganz viele offene fragen
lee baca aber ich sitze hier in einem
wohnzimmer einer dieser mutigen frauen
die in linz demonstrieren des ist olesja
sie spricht perfekt deutsch weil die
deutschlehrerin ist oder es ja du bist
als demonstranten in den vergangenen
tagen und wochen immer dort gewesen
viele menschen wurden gefoltert brutal
zusammengeschlagen frauen teilweise
vergewaltigt woher nimmst du die mut den
not vorher nimmt ihr alle den mut da
immer wieder zu demonstrieren
das ist schwer
die waren ich war so erschüttert von den
von den bilder die wir gesehen haben von
all diesen schrecklichen verhaftungen
von blut wir konnten einfach nicht zu
hause bleiben
wir mussten ich musste immer auf die iss
auf die straße ich musste meinen protest
zeigen
natürlich können wir nicht klagen
gleichgültig bleiben so was gab es nie
in unserem land und wir konnten uns so
was auch nie vorstellen dass es sowas
wie bekannt
natürlich gingen wie auf die straßen und
protestierten woher aber nimmt ihr den
oberschenkel hat sich jetzt mit einem
sturmgewehr gezeigt er hat gesagt ab
morgen will er möglicherweise hier ein
crackdown veranstalten du gehst auf die
straße und riskiert damit ihr am ende
auch ins gefängnis zu kommen und
möglicherweise brutal zugerichtet zu
werden wie andere von den berüchtigten
um uns bezahlt aber ich frage mich immer
sage mir immer wenn ich jetzt nicht
protestieren denn heißt dass diese leute
haben umsonst gestorben
sie wurden umsonst gefoltert und sie
haben ihr leben einfach so umsonst
verloren und das kann ich nicht zulassen
das kann ich nicht verzeihen das kann
ich nicht vergessen
deswegen würde ich jeden tag
protestieren und wir schwören einander
jeden tag am hauptplatz an als sie
abends zum hauptplatz gehen es gibt
unmengen eine ungewollte dort und wir
stören einander dass wir am nächsten tag
wiederkommen wir skandieren jeden tag
jeden tag und das heißt er dass er als
uns stören und das wort halten
jetzt waren heute wieder hunderttausende
auf den straßen aber lukaschenko ist
immer noch präsident er ist immer noch
dort wann glaubst du ist der zeitpunkt
das ergehen wird oder wird er überhaupt
gehen wir haben die ersten tage sehr
gehofft darauf dass er wirklich geht
denn unsere denn die fälschung war so
offensichtlich die wirkung die leute
leute der vielen leute der mehrheit war
so offensichtlich dass wir fast glaubten
er kann's kartieren und weggehen aber
leider nicht und mit der zeit haben wir
verstanden dass es auch nicht mehr sein
wird das erst nie aufgeben das land nie
aufgeben wird wird es am ende so
gewaltsam dann funktionieren glaubst du
dass das umschwenken könnte hier in
einer art bürgerkrieg von der gewalt in
will niemand hören niemand wissen
die du gerade gesagt hast wir sind sehr
friedliche leute wir beschädigen keine
vitrinen oder noch etwas wir hoffen ja
ich persönlich mache was ich kann ich
gehe auf die straße und ich hoffe nur
auf das beste ich weiß nicht was diesen
mann beeinflussen kann und er ist der
letzte frage an dich in dieser runde die
bei uns in berlin diskutiert setzen
viele politiker oder ausschließlich fast
politiker und die große frage ist was
kann aus deiner sicht europa jetzt tun
braucht es schärfere sanktionen
das ist eine zu komplizierte frage für
mich vielleicht wären die sanktionen
doch gut obwohl sie für den normalen für
die einfachen menschen etwas auf schönes
mitbringen
aber vielleicht würde durch eine
ökonomische krise die leute zu den
gedanken bringen
das etwas zu ändern dass das ihr etwas
ändern müssen denn heutzutage wir hatten
wir nichts an allen betriebsmitarbeiter
man leider unterstützt die
protestierenden
vielen dank für diese ausführung das was
du machst das was alle frauen dort und
alle menschen heute auf den straßen
getan haben glaube ich bewegt die
menschen in deutschland und ganz europa
und was ich sagen kann
bild wird weiter berichten und zeigen
passieren wenn es passiert und lässt ja
und jetzt lieber kai das waren die
ausführungen einer demonstrantin direkt
aus ihrem wohnzimmer hiermit die ganzen
tag protestiert hat und sich jetzt noch
zeit genommen hat für die richtigen
fragen tagebaue vor allen dingen danke
olesja wie paul schon sagt wir sind bei
den menschen dort mit dir in minsk wo
demonstriert wird und wir sind dann
abends auf dem sofa auf der auf der
couch dort in minsk und hoffen weiter
irgendwie unterstützen zu können das war
die entscheidende frage wie können wir
das tun und die frage will ich bleibt
deswegen noch ein ganz lament
zugeschaltet paul an manfred weber vor
allen dingen weitergeben denn so die
ganz ganz schweren eindruck scheint
bisher bei lukaschenko ja noch nicht
gemacht zu haben dass man die wahl nicht
anerkannt hat das heißt olesja wünscht
sich ein bisschen mehr noch
unterstützung was genau
die europäische union hat kurz nach den
wahlfälschungen nachdem das ergebnis
bekanntgegeben worden
das treffen der staats und
regierungschefs abgehalten und dabei
klargestellt dass wir das ergebnis nicht
respektieren das war politisch ein
wichtiges signal weil europa immer nur
dann stark ist der dicke 1 über gott sei
dank sind wir in dieser frage jetzt
gelernt und jetzt gilt es darum nicht
den in die falle auch der populisten der
der falsch informiert auf der russischen
seite zu gehen nämlich die allen
erzählen das sei ja eine initiative aus
den besten die belarus people wollen das
gar nicht und deswegen müssen wir
vernünftig vorgehen auch hier sage ich
dass sanktionen gegenüber russland
sollte russland aktiv werden wirklich
eingreifen hart eingreifen
auf dem tisch liegen aber wir müssen
alles vermeiden um den vorschub zu
leisten die sagen das ist keine sache
die die menschen wollen sondern die der
westen will und man kann nur mit tiefer
respekt dann gesagt wird ihnen die da
auf die straße gehen
der diese idee von freiheit die kämpft
sich vor 1990 war sie in leipzig 2014
was dann in der ukraine in kiew
jetzt sind belarus und es wird auch
irgendwann in moskau sein ja das ist
schön wenn das am ende dieses happy end
gibt trotzdem sehen wir den präsidenten
ja heute mit kalaschnikow aus dem
hubschrauber aussteigen herr trittin das
heißt so lässt er wünscht sich ganz
konkrete hilfe er weber sagte jetzt erst
mal müssen die lämmer wir wollen ja
nicht diejenigen sein denen dann der
vorwurf gemacht werden kann so recht er
hat durch da ein gemischte in
weißrussland was macht man jetzt also
wie kriegt man lukaschenko weg für die
identifizierbaren verantwortlichen für
übergriffe und ähnlichen muss es nach
meiner festen überzeugung
personenbezogene sanktionen geben die
dürfen dann halt nicht mehr nach europa
reisen werden sie wahrscheinlich zu
werden sie von diesen kunden aber es
gibt noch einen weiteren aspekt 80
prozent des handels von belarus findet
mit russland statt aber es gibt
relevante teile übrigens eines der werke
wo man den arbeitern mit gewalt verboten
hat zu streiken müssen traktorenfabrik
warum dürfen die noch geschäfte mit uns
ab ich finde solche elemente ganz klar
auf den tisch zu legen zusagen für uns
ist da eine grenze erreicht wenn
menschen in ihrem streikrecht gehindert
werden
dann machen wir mit einer solchen firma
keine geschäfte mehr punkt das nehmen
wir mit wir werden den nächsten tagen
sehr genau drauf gucken was die nächsten
schritte sind um die menschen dort in
weißrussland eben zu unterstützen
herzlichen dank ihnen allen an dieser
runde am sonntagabend und wir alle
schauen ein bisschen gebannt auch nach
lissabon heute wohl nämlich fußball
gespielt wird wie sie alle wissen das
spiel hat gerade begonnen und wir werden
uns dann in der halbzeitpause hierbei
bild melden mit jetzt kommt all das
heißt wir wechseln mich aus gegen
matthias brügelmann und wechselte jürgen
trittin aus gegen mehmet scholl das dann
in 45 minuten hier live bei bild
[Musik]